I want to ask what would you do if you  were in your dad shoes and you didn't  come to us until you were 23 you know i  wanna i want to believe that if i came  to the US in the way that my dad did  which was not only a 23 years old but  also with a child and another one on the  way that I would do the same thing that  he did which was completely work as face  off to allow the next generation to kind  of build on top of that and so you know  I don't think I would have done anything  different um yeah I think a lot of its  circumstance my dad had a great-uncle  who had a liquor store that he got to  work in that great uncle passed away and  it was just all these kind of different  variables i think circumstance has a lot  to do with what i would have done but  the one thing I know I would have done  is work every hour of every day oh crap  wait subscribe I need subscriptions  because I can't push this many right  hooks in social so subscribe